the wonder of theo is that i don't know
what you're gonna say
from minute to minute okay i don't know
when you're on
stage i don't know what you're gonna say
you're gonna so
i so my point is i don't know what you
know
i have no idea what you know okay as i
told you you
you doing your act you look like a guy
who who has matches right
yep i believe that you look like uh
if if i could be anywhere in the world
if you text me and said
i'm outside i would believe it okay
i would come and get like just yep that
theo's outside that makes
any [ __ ] anywhere in the world i
gotta go to get theo what we're at the
united nations
he's outside okay
i believe that i don't know what so the
question is i don't know what you know
and i feel like you know
i know you know more than i think you
know okay but i don't know
what the breadth of the knowledge is
okay
so we're gonna play a game show called
what
does theo know i want you to play along
at home maybe you'll throw some music
underneath this some game show music
um play along at home what does theo
know do i just tell you things
uh no i'm gonna ask you questions and
what and then people will guess
whether you know it or not all right
okay and i'm gonna guess too
yeah you will you will tell us i'll tell
you if i think you know
you'll weigh in he knows you know what
he knows
i think i know but i don't know what you
know yeah no one knows what theo knows
all right all right
let's do it name five members of the
1985
chicago bears i believe you know this
you almost don't because of your age but
i believe you can muscle it out
all right i'm gonna go with your boy um
uh
sean gale who murdered his wife you
[ __ ] know what then if you know sean
gale but i know that because i'm a
dateline fanatic
outside of that i'm going with your boy
oh i will go with this
uh uh the quarterback that legend jim
uh mcmahon okay who i met at a golf
tournament out in palm springs
and he had this little kind of thick
jewish woman as his girlfriend and she
said he
he goes this lady will always eat my
butt that's what he told me which was
kind of crazy i thought
that's the sort of thing i expected you
to know yeah
and bro i watched him drink 18 beers man
at this point yeah that guy's a while
he's wild
yeah and he would stand up when he would
say that about the lady and he would
kind of he had pants on he was like kind
of pull his butt apart which was crazy
and uh and i think i got high with them
actually but um
but anyway so sean gayle shanghai i
don't know if was on that team
that he might have been after that team
but i'll give you sean gayle and i'll
absolutely jimmy right now
let's go your boy richard dent right
there richard yeah if you know richard
denton you're going to
i'm going to go with sweetness walter
payton yep we're up to four and i'm
gonna go with um
of course who else is it it's that guy
uh refrigerator perry
yeah keep go who else do you know sean
gail the killer right there
uh yep he was on the team yeah he was
i believe he returned kickoffs i believe
he returned his wife to heaven too dude
uh yeah roni reuter willie gault
returned for that oh will he go willy
gone yeah
goddamn dude black people used to have
more much more kind of old school names
i feel like yeah they had like
it was before the apostrophes and the
quans and
yeah willy goat you know they had like
southern
they had like uh uh uh sharecroppers
names yeah they had definitely like
holdover like
second third hand kind of yeah names
like that like i remember like uh
you'd meet a guy named lilac or
something like that and you'd be like
that is the cr
you know ll llac yeah
like the like the flower yes or toby um
or toby yeah all right toby's a little
toby's a little really tell me i can't
get i can't and you don't even know
i can't endorse that name can theo von
name
four films directed by spike lee
i think you can
i don't think i can but i'm going to do
it um
i'm going to audience think about your
answer before he begins
first of all i don't like spike lee okay
so
that's why i picked him he's a he's a
he's a political
yeah i think he just looks like [ __ ] i
don't care about the
direct i mean i yeah some of the movies
are whatever i mean i liked
definitely white men can't jump and
poetic justice
he was not involved in either of them
are you serious he got in he wasn't even
close to them were you thinking he got
game with denzel that was likely
i was thinking about white men can't
jump whiteman can't jump you're thinking
of
he got game you're thinking of yeah i
don't know i just think western times is
overrated that's what i mean i shouldn't
say i don't like him i shouldn't say he
looks like [ __ ] i just
you know he looks like somebody that
[ __ ] managed a like a uh
like one of those places at the dave and
busters we go cash in the tickets he
looks like the dude that managed that
for like 40 years
and then i just don't think he made that
much good stuff what did he make
you so that's you can't you that's
you could not answer no that's
interesting okay all right that's the
i figure there might be a limit there
but i'm surprised but i'm still
surprised
oh well mac mca matt malcolm malcolm x
you ever see malcolm
i haven't seen malcolm x yeah that's
yeah
that's but yeah from like 91 oh yeah
that's spike
wow yeah uh black clams you see that
no i didn't see anything um
jungle fever she's gotta have it
uh
yeah i mean he started taking nails
pretty regularly i just think it is
overrated i'm sure he's probably a neat
guy
yeah 25th hour people like that movie i
didn't like that movie bamboozled
he got game he got game you know what's
great about he got game
he's just watching ray uh alan shoot
really so it's ray allen plays like a
college basketball phenom
yeah and there's scenes where him and
denzel are arguing
and ray allen's shooting jumpers and he
makes like nine in a row from three at
one point
but it's in this it's in a scene and
there's no edits right
and it's [ __ ] you never see someone
shoot like that like
it's [ __ ] cr it's crazy because you
just see a guy just make where you like
are you
you know you ever watch like steph uh
steph curry videos where he's just like
and you're like this is weird yeah like
he's almost haunted
electronics yeah like that yeah like he
might be a witch that's wanted by a
video game yeah this one i think you
will get
all right name three people
who have served as governor of
california
oh gavin newsom mm-hmm uh sunny
uh sun uh i know this
i can't believe you're about to say who
you're gonna say really i can't believe
that you i cuz i didn't even remember
this one
i don't know if i remember but let me
think
reed i think his name was sunshine brown
uh
um sun sherry yes jerry sunshine
sometimes like his nickname yeah
sunshine jerry
jerry jerry brown uh-huh wow
and uh oh viaragosa
and uh antonin viaragosa no i don't
think he was governor
it wasn't yeah i thought
those were the ones i thought you would
get i thought you might get pete wilson
there was a second governor of he's
really old but
his name was sunny james sonny jim no
i did not even know that you'll be
honest did you mean sonny jim rome
no that guy looks like he definitely has
your he would get sunburned he does he
would have to wear
leather driving gloves if he drove my
family around look at that mustache
what a mustache that's a goddamn um all
right
question number four
theo what is it and do you think theo
knows the answer
does theo know what a carburetor
is and does
yes yes he does
going to say i think it does you think
so yeah this is the sort of thing i
expect you to know
but if you told me you didn't i because
you're a carburetor
i feel like
i feel like a carburetor takes heat off
of the engine
what do you think nick i have no idea
does it have smoke in it i'm looking at
it
carburetor that carburetor
i like that you're trying to think of
the times you've heard it
people talk about it yeah a carburetor
is a device that mixes air and fuel for
internal combustion engine the proper
fuel yeah i don't know
that carb you got to use that car and
look what they call in australia you'll
like this
what a car bee a carbine of course
because it's australia
they put a y on the back of everything i
met a guy from
australia the other day um
that carby yeah so carver all right so
that i bet a lot of people are surprised
you didn't know because i didn't really
know and i still don't even now that i
know what it is i'm like i don't really
know what that is
it feels like it's part of the engine
yeah it sounds like it
is that carburetor boy it is part of the
engine but
i don't i let's not count that one oh
i'm counting it okay count it
so you did know the bears you didn't
know spike lee you did know california
you did not know what a carburetor is
okay here's one okay
will theo know what aids
is an acronym for
i think you will
i'm going to go with autoimmune
deficiency
syndrome that is correct i believe it's
acquired immune but
it might be autoimmune either one is
right
nick
acquired but auto i mean it's fine do
you
uh have did you ever think you had had
aids and got tested for it
no i mean other people think i have it
really um look at me
um i would never think aids no i know
the age like something lesser like hiv
like you're not full-blown you think
maybe that you had a neighbor
that had polio that's what
i never no but you remember having sex
in the
90s it was like a it was
you it was scary it was oh there was
definitely a fear
think about it like really think about
aids more than i think about stds now
you would think am i gonna die from this
oh i remember being so angry at somebody
when i was young that i told people they
had aids
how old
man like height grade school high school
now that i sounded out
probably graduate school
probably 29 yeah wow
were they funny bro i don't want to know
any follow-ups i don't want to know
anymore
did they have to they ever confront you
about it
no man it's not funny and i hope that
they're doing good too okay
i believe you're gonna know this name
two books by ernest hemingway oh i know
this one
what did the audience think he kind of
told me i would i would have guessed yes
i think he knows literature quite a bit
actually
i hear some some crazy references pulled
out and i'm going to go with
sun also rises and moby dick
he did not write moby dick i had the
same serious yeah i had the same
thought and i can't remember who wrote
did one of his friends write it
who wrote it oh man i can't remember
either it is
herman melville ah
do you want a third you want to guess a
different one
hemingway no i just knew that one that
had us right read in high school ernest
hemingway
i never really liked him in a way man i
thought it was good i think muriel's
pretty hot
but i never i haven't read any of it you
haven't no it was always a little
i don't know short i like the short
sentences he was like super into like
outdoorsy guy [ __ ] right
yeah he hunted and still like
yeah this is kind of early cameron hanes
i guess
um all right we did not i'm surprised
sorry folks he did not know
this one i think you're gonna know name
three songs
can you name three songs by def leppard
let me think about it def leppard
i would say uh
that's not def leopard um
no [ __ ] i would have guessed you did
i would have guessed i was gonna say
cherry pie that's what i was gonna say
that's warrant that's warrant yeah
that's warm bro [ __ ] love warrant
uh here we got the old man in the sea
for whom the bell tolls
that's those are not death leopard songs
though
that is hemingway books in our time
sun also rises fairweather arms do you
haven't have enough for whom the bell
tolls the old man good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one